metro police are really noticing an
uptick in calls about dogs who are being
left in hot cars
they released this footage showing a
weekend rescue apparently the owners
were shopping at the time left the dog
in the car with that cone on was later
arrested
metro says between june 1st and july 11
animal control teams have received 38
calls regarding dogs and cars
some officers have been forced to break
the windows in order to rescue those
animals
undersheriff christopher darcy says they
take animal cruelty
very seriously and people should report
it if they're concerned
call us we're equipped to handle that
we'll send an officer out there we'll
evaluate the situation
our detective detectives and officers
will respond
if needed we'll evaluate the situation
and maybe we'll have to break the window
or we'll be able to locate the owner
so this is video actually of a different
incident this was on friday
two dogs rescued from inside this car
parked in a casino parking garage they
did break the window in this case
the dogs were inside the car for four
hours no food
no water the good samaritan law in
nevada does not permit citizens though
from breaking windows in order to rescue
cars luckily somebody called it in
and it was reported so we asked you on
twitter today
when you see an animal in a hot car do
you think citizens should be allowed to
break a window to
save the animal or do you think citizens
should just make that 9-1-1 call and
wait here it is overwhelming
79 percent of you said yes you should be
allowed to break the window
while 21 percent said no wait for police